من موسكو رانيا الدريدي رانيا كيف ينظر
الى
تاخر روسيا الرسميه باصدار اي اعلان عن
مصير حتى الان
[تصفيق]
يعني في واقع الامر جلال هذا امر طبيعي لا
يمكن ان تقوم لجنه التحقيقات الروسيه
باصدار اي معطيات فيما يتعلق بمصير يعني
ايا كان من ركاب هذه الطائره طالما عمليه
التحقيقات التحقيقات ولجنه التحقيقات لا
تزال يعني تقوم بعملها ولا توجد يعني
معطيات رسميه صادره عنها التحقيقات لم
تنتهي حتى هذه اللحظه هناك العديد من
المعطيات العديد من التساؤلات العديد من
القصص ان صح التعبير المتعلقه بهذه
الطائره ولكن رسميا حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم
انهاء عمليات التحقيق هناك عدد من
الروايات جلال المتعلقه بهذه الطائره وما
حدث على متنها رسميا حتى هذه اللحظه ما هو
معروف هو انه كان علامات هذه الطائره 10
اشخاص من بينهم ثلاثه اشخاص من افراد
الطاقم وفقا للائحه الطيران فان من بين
اسماء من كان
[ضحك]
هناك شهود عيان يتحدثون عن عن سماع ذوي
انفجارين على متن الطائره قبل سقوطها هناك
حديث عن تحطم
جناح هذه الطائره قبل سقوطها اضافه الى
ذلك ذيل الطائره سقط في مكان بعيد عن مكان
سقوط الهيكل الكامل للطائره وبالتالي
الروايه الاولى تتحدث عن امكانيه وجود عطل
تقني على متن هذا الطائره تسبب بسقوطها
هناك ايضا روايه تتحدث عن عن وجود يعني او
اتخاذ قرارات خاطئه من قبل طاقم هذه
الطائره ما تسبب بتحطمها هناك ايضا روايه
تتحدث عن ان هذا عمل ارهابي قد يكون هناك
قنبله ناسفه مزروعه على متن هذه الطائره
لاسيما وان بعض المصادر غير الرسميه تحدثت
عن ان هذه الطائره وقبل اقلاعها من
العاصمه موسكو باتجاه مدينه سانت
بتروسبورغ يعني تعرضت لعمليات اصلاح وت في
عمليه الاقلاع اذا كل هذه الروايات وارده
وهناك ايضا روايه رابعه ان صح التعبير
جمال تتحدى يتحدث الخبراء عن وجود بعض
الثقوب في جناح الطائره الذي سقط قبل سقوط
الطائره وايضا مساله سقوط ذيل هذه الطائره
بمكان بعيد عن الهيكل بشكل عام هذا قد ينم
عن تعرض هذه الطائره لاي قصف جوي على سبيل
المثال تعرضها لاستهداف من قبل انظمه
الدفاع الجوي اذا هناك روايات كثيره
معطيات كثيره كثيره عمليه التحقيق لا تزال
قائمه وعليه يعني من السابق لاوانه يعني
ان نتحدث عن يعني مصير بريجوجن على الاقل
وفقا للمعطيات الرسميه حتى هذه اللحظه
جلال شكرا لك في موسكو